who is the greatest comedian that ever
lived the greatest community the
greatest who was the biggest influence
red fox red fox was your biggest
influence red fox was the greatest
i've seen red fox a couple of times i've
seen him do two hours
wow one time and he got the crowd up he
was funny and then he got
so terrible he he took him so bad he
took him down
that they were leaving they were and he
went to the door and opened the door for
him what was that and they ran out
do you think he didn't know when he was
funny he knew he had that control
he could do anything he wanted with
another why would he want to make them
hate him
because that's part of the the game you
know to get him to love you
and then get him to hate you and then
get him to love you again really
that it was so easy he played games like
that
steve martin steve martin's in that
caliber
yeah steve martin could take any
audience and do anything he wants with
him
wow i mean yeah i've read his book steve
martin and in the early days he
describes his learning his craft it was
like science to him
yeah [ __ ] with the audience and
seeing what the hell he could get out of
well he had the best
teacher an empty room you know no one
coming in and you had to do your comedy
yeah it's almost impossible to learn how
to do that in front of a
huge crowd no you can't and lenny bruce
was one of your influences yeah right
i would think big time big time no but
lenny wasn't of the
same caliber as as martin or
red red fox no i mean what i'm talking
about is
you know any you know most comedians can
make you laugh for a while you know
right but to take an audience up and
then bring them
down and like i've only seen steve
martin and red fox the only ones that
did it what about richard pryor
well richard pryor would do it but he
would richard was more
if richard was stoned really stoned you
know
coked out or something you'd see some
incredible stuff that you go whoa
you know oh i don't know if i wanted to
see that
but but but when he was when he was like
getting very popular in that
he he never took that that extra one
where he would
take him he'd just make you laugh and
laugh and laugh was george
carlin uh one of the greats yes he was
definitely
carlin was more of a wordsmith you know
right yeah he could do anything with
words